so the training is trying to basically
it's a drill for mirroring or exposing
or reflecting your enlightenment skill
can I detach my mind's gonna get
captured and can I now practice who free
my mind okay so I think it was the other
day that was up where we were talking
about setting up so you're being set up
let's say for the 54 and you should be
able to you have to be able to feel my
mind I locked into that and immediately
were you got to go and assess what else
is happening otherwise you're going to
be set up the real attacks not the
figure-four in the use of force class
every single one where you had that you
dilute violation it's because the guy
did not reorient right to the new thing
why because they got sucked into the
first thing right so this is a drill you
can kind of think of it as like you know
under sucking yourself pulling yourself
back out okay so you can't stop as I
talk because you're getting sucked into
my talking you have to keep doing what
you're doing so I'm gonna talk through
it okay so we establish the rule of this
right he has to do that
then he can do whatever right so as as
I'm going I try not to speed up I'm
trying to watch my my intention I'm
trying to check him out where I can
[Music]
I'm really observing myself in that way
is very much is a moving meditation
that's fine
[Music]
okay let's go so the same way that I
working things I'm promit izing what I'm
doing what I'm doing on the on the
inside okay so this like head over here
this was treated and quite readily by
most to you like I feel like that's
energy right but when she goes to turn
to me this now is not treated like this
in your mind but it's not different
right so she I go here she goes there
it's just the same thing and meaning
that things just suck to reconcile it's
not stuff to freak out about okay
[Music]
I make sure I breathe I make sure my
feet on the ground because my feet movie
is my anxiety response just like my CD
my breath holding
just wait there
[Music]
okay so right all that is oh I'm getting
stuck getting stuff breathe reassess
right the whole battlefield so my my my
mind is you can do whatever
right so it's here's looking look inside
so you're on one leg and now hit me hit
me hard
you see do you understand that not at
the cost of what everything else I have
so I see you don't have a knife right go
ahead it's all right so I have to go
ahead I have to address the combination
of the move of motion right I have to be
fluid in that sense but that's not quite
like here I have to be spontaneous with
my IP applications
you got that and so the difference is
like
[Music]
right see how I use that to get him off
balance
so he goes boom you see that weight
shift is what does boom the weight shift
that we shift their test right then it
should you get these little mixtures of
it you can't really take your whole
technique can speed up okay but you'll
find that you'll see that a lot when
Leah was like grabbing my leg right and
I just moving my leg and it had her fall
okay so I'm going yep there's the IQ
right then take that yen space to his
yawn
[Music]
to the yielding of it if you die you go
don't worry I gotta talk right to that
you add your mixtures which we cope you
lightly
there's spritzing the sticky parts right
these sticky parts
[Music]
sorry
and so I don't get tired not here you
see find IIT it's inside it's inside so
I use this grip to tell me no that's not
it
stay inside inside it I'm thinking this
part on my body part sink inside inside
not this part here here you see what
it's doing go back so here I'm freaking
out right but here I've seen the arm bar
with just disappearing inside against or
not against but despite his grab you
there's room inside okay
don't welcome my new feature especially
when your teachers are come any
questions things I man I keep doing it I
keep getting stuck in this this is what
keeps happening to me any comments any
observations yes
from where
okay so let's set up that throne and you
beat her tell them what what situation
so I'm going to pull out a solution I
gave you when I was with you okay so I
go over here and look at look at my
dynamics so as he's as he's moving relax
just we're like two airplanes on a stick
a case you don't do anything with your
hands okay as he's starting to move
forward I'm starting to move to this
corner you see that so I don't wait here
wait wait wait and then I go here so
again he goes he's doing that and I'm
gonna go here so that now he has a
missile that can fire on the curve and
you're gonna get nailed what I'm doing
instead is he's moving and I'm moving
away from that do you see see there
right and he does that same curve it is
not there he's gonna have to take one
more step see so that's her solar
sanctuary you guys remember that so it's
the corners of the fight
so once the the attacker his weapons in
their individual vectors make up a
particular circumference and if I put
that circumference inside a square those
corners of the square roots are your
zones of sanctuary they are the closest
you can be to him and the furthest you'd
need to be away from you okay so as I go
and I work there and I stick something
in
you see and I'm holding him this is the
one I was doing on you so you go back
and watch the video and he he can't get
that shredder you see that just just
from me being off that corner but you do
the other one do you see then you're not
so it's a positioning thing that when
the five starts moving you need to be on
that angle that's not to say that he
can't parry my strike you see that but
if he has to reorient himself to my new
positioning so you can throw the Perry
right you see so as tough as the fight
mood carries right I'm a winner
I keep staying in those corner you see
that until I can get the spiral going
then he's close to me but he's actually
behind me so this was kept going with
Brody
you see right
so you can't stay still that's the
beginner mistake and you can't move
whatever if we're if we're boxing and
he's trying to close the gap I wouldn't
move I'd moved to that corner it'd make
him have to adjust okay so let's do just
this variation key all right I'm trying
to do that then he parries it and that
just tells me to go there don't go there
that's not what you're trying to learn
okay so my my strike boom you got a pair
of hit right I am occupy him you see
there's stuff on it right even though
I'm going slow it's not like this off to
the side of the strip we see the
response do you understand the situation
but that's not it it's not impacting his
dance at all I can't transition to yen
because I was already in so he hit this
place boom he walks into it then don't
mistake this for content Nadia it's not
writing on it it's an application of
content knocking so yes I have a
rotational throw but what do you always
look for projecting across the spiral
got it
so I generate a spiral and then I
project across the spiral you can't do
Titan on me from here as keep on because
you don't have the head
and you're not in the right spot so find
the new spot we saw on the outside of
his head there's my diagonal you see
that and then I projected CrossFit he's
got energy in this grip see so i project
with the grip boom back again right
if he has no energy in it like a lot of
you because you're freaking out because
your head went down then I tapped
directly because that's the in space so
grip strong you see young space in space
follow the in space in you see that do
not expect yourself you're gonna go here
like this and you're gonna go like this
like you're doing pipe minami this is
not a tsunami so in charity home to it
and one level you can see there's just
certain personal obstacles that get in
the way you can you can you can
intellectually grasp that doing a
technique in a kihon setting is just a
world apart from doing a technique in a
live setting
and the means of developing skill in the
two settings are totally different there
may be individual components that
overlap but the means of developing the
skill are totally different and so when
you're in I want to do a technique in a
live setting you task yourself with that
you realize that there are some very
personal obstacles to developing that
skill you can intellectually grasp that
it's in a different environment you can
intellectually grasp what you're trying
to do but that intellectual grasping
kind of gets more mileage in ki Han look
here's the fulcrum here's the lever
here's an angle of cancelation here's an
angle disturbance and then over here
sight intellectually comprehend all you
f & wad you're not going to get it so go
deeper what's what other faculties help
me absorb and transform absorb
information transform myself beyond my
intellect and what other faculties
whether what other aspects of my being
stopped me or hinder me
from this absorption and this
transformation that now you're doing
Buddha
so some of the things I'm seeing here
I'm just not going to do that variation
I'm gonna do this other thing as if it's
equal
[Music]
and you'll see you'll see because Budo
doesn't reveal what you do butoh reveals
who you are so if you're live training
environment you show a propensity for
choosing crappy responses over martially
sound responses I guarantee you
everywhere else in your life you show it
in capacity for choosing wiser courses
better courses more efficient courses
you have a difficulty prioritizing
valuing what should be valued you don't
just do it in this little live
environment TVV the why why do I do that
and I guarantee you when you when you go
down that dark hole hole you're not
gonna find a navigable trade you should
be keeping you're going to find
something you need to drop so Bruno
training is that it's like it's a it is
a process of elimination just like crap
leaving your body
the transformation that you're seeking
is not so much you adopting as much as
is you getting rid of crap
so we've been told a million times don't
stay on the line
the fights already moved you need to
adapt you've been given metaphors look
it's just like dog fighter planes the
little toy models they used to teach
dogfighting angles you've been given
analogous situations it's like boxing is
like tennis it's like any other sport
you've been given two-dimensional
diagrams look it's like a circle and a
square but you can't stop it because
none of those things have anything to do
with why you keep it in a lot of
situations it's not an understanding
thing
it's a beam thing so the ancient
traditions understood this much better
than we moderns
you can't fix beam things with textbooks
and certificates and seminars it can't
be done so a very simple technology is
the mentor disciple relationship
you move because the person who you
should be able to value told you to move
[Music]
you're not giving me anything cause you
moved and I told you to move I don't go
home and good I feel so good
I got Leah to move that's a whole ego
smokescreen that the modern rule tells
themselves because they're wrapped up in
the fantasy that if only you have some
power you'd stop being depressed and
bipolar and self-medicating and your
life would be perfect this has nothing
to do with Buddha nothing to do with
Ikey nothing to do in Aikido the true
death she knows man I can't get this
so I'm going to use other components of
my being
I'm gonna use my emotions my heart my
sense of awe
to help me find new reasons being to
help me drop things I'm holding on to
and I don't even know why only I know I
should not be holding on to them so the
teacher says that's where I'm going
the teacher is a technology it's not a
person in your fantasies of hierarchies
with kings at the top the teacher is
just the technology for self
transformation it's a tool the teacher
is a tool to help you go that's where I
go
if you if you can't get a teacher you're
gonna want to ask this if I can't do
that with my teacher
Tate all this goes out it does it just
goes away you're going to get stuck like
the rest of the world I'm going to make
a big deal out of keyhole awesome
because why because they're being
doesn't really matter it's all an
intellectual process
[Music]
till you might go around and you might I
just gotta find a teacher I can do it
with no the teacher wasn't the problem
you're the problem you don't have the
capacity in you to self displace to make
the tool viable
here you go through the history of world
religions and religions of all kinds in
the world and you're going to see that
the tool is a rock and the naive person
goes it must be a very special rock look
at it it's so beautiful
this rock is so beautiful I can feel
some power coming off of it wolf or 1099
I'll cut a little chip off and you could
take it home in this little bottle and
you can put it on your altar in your out
oh wait it's a tree over here there's
the truth woman oh oh look at this tree
for $15.99 I'll give you a splinter and
you can put it in this little envelope
and you can put it next to that little
rock shaving in your you're not getting
it
the tool works because you empower it
with what with you
[Music]
and so when you can't empower it then
you know what you got a problem it's not
out there it's your problem well I don't
have that fuel so guess what
you got to go back the step go get some
fuel that's where all the rest of the
dojo comes in help you figure it out the
rules to educate the culture the work
the community
the trials
it's time to give you fuel
[Music]
but in a certain level you the deci
gotta figure you gotta get to this point
I need some fuel so I can get my tools
of transformation besides my intellect
working
whoops don't have fuel I gotta get some
fuel
in the old days you had to come in with
your fuel thank you got no fuel get out
oh my got time for you but I'm going to
worship you like a king I don't give a
get out you're draining me
I would like to be worship like a king
go do it it's easy here's a black belt
go start your own crap somewhere else
get away from me
[Music]
but we don't we don't have that fuel
anymore so this dojo we try to get the
fuel we try to help you get the fuel but
you got to bring it in everyone on the
mats that they should have enough fuel
you should have enough fuel to go since
they said not to stay on the line so I'm
not staying on the line you'll feel
yourself I don't know where to move I
don't know where to move okay you got
enough fuel to go who gives a move
off the line you got enough fuel
everyone here has enough fuel you're
just not using it now you're going back
to your old place I'm pretty sure okay
he's been training a while but he does
not know me and I might be that rare
exception that should stay on the line I
could be that guy or maybe you maybe
he's you know he's just human and
everybody's wrong I should probably
figure out where I should move before I
move that makes sense to me
see now you're back stuck on yourself so
where's the transformation that's just
you being you you already are a black
belt in that
[Music]
I guarantee you it doesn't it doesn't
matter just move because spiritually
that's the training my mind wants to
stop my body wants to stop my ego wants
to figure it all out and make sure it's
safe before I do anything that's you
being you just move now you're not you
yeah but I didn't do a technique what
who gives a you're not supposed to
be doing techniques techniques are over
here in kion over here
you're supposed to be transforming the
self towards enlightenment and that's
the process of dropping all that crap
that is the old you so you're thinking
and trying to figuring up I sold you
it's not the right training it's now
puto
he just move and what is the difference
in a GU setting what's the difference
I moved what's he have to do in the
hooter Lou he's got to reorient himself
well I'm sure there's better and worse
places of moving not until you stop
moving when you stay moving and you stay
in a relationship to the attacker
there's no right or wrong place to be
this idea that there's better and worse
places of moving and the stopping that
is related to it that's the old you
that's the stuck on you there's nothing
wrong with what the person is doing you
making it wrong you're forcing things
so it's a very simple technology of the
self the teacher and you will find it
throughout any tradition where
spontaneity of art is the ultimate goal
you can go way back and you will find
that man has known for centuries and
centuries and centuries that we get
stubborn ourselves and while we have
this great brain it can often hinder us
but we have other faculties other
aspects and we can use other devices to
help us skip past ourselves and one of
them is a mentor
so if when we do this how much more do I
need to say get moving get off the line
stop waiting it's too long right spend
years for some of you you can't do it
anymore just get off the line just take
a step who cares we're in that step you
are closer to what you want then in you
trying to find the perfect technique